uh now i know you better i wish i knew
as much about you and i kind of delved
in because and we'll talk about this
your new show which is off the charts as
we see you see it on amazon prime as we
see it which is like the number one show
on amazon prime it's got you know like
if you can give it six stars it's got
six stars it's brilliant it's this is to
say five
because i think it's worth more than the
stars that are giving you extra like
when rock and rollers like bring turn it
up to 11 that's what it is right but it
and and for those that haven't seen it
you have to watch it because it is based
on the life of three uh people who are
in the spectrum
and um
[Music]
what is also kind of amazing about it
not only is it well written and
brilliantly acted
but everybody in the cast
is legitimately in the spectrum is that
correct i didn't i don't know the girl
uh suan and i think technically and i
want you to get cancelled it's on the
spectrum
i was talking about color the shades
right right yeah well suanne right she's
uh asian and albert and i are white so
you should have albert on the podcast i
was wrong it's on the spectrum uh on the
spectrum yeah and you were die
diagnosed actually um five years ago uh
yeah i've been following you so i saw
you and you were brilliant on uh with
trevor noah
on the daily show on the daily it's my
first late night i've been drew i've
been
i've been wanting to do it late night
for the it's not the same typical like
sitting on a couch and doing bits and
stuff but that was my first late night i
was so excited to do it and you were
brilliant on it because you were not
only articulate and smart but you were
funny and charming and uh
you have become more than just a
comedian but an advocate
are you do you consider yourself an
advocate for autism no
no
uh i don't
i don't
that scares me a bit because and and i
was really glad that organically it came
up the way it did when i did that
interview with trevor because i was able
to tell him that i don't want to be an
advocate for something i'm still
learning about which he thought was a
brilliant statement and was also allowed
me to kind of like get hey listen i i
don't know much and now i could be
present in like not pretending or are
you thinking and pretending but what has
been happening with
this show because it's been doing well
and there's been so much press and
that's kind of like the talking point a
lot well because we have not well i
guess we have i mean if there is a show
about living in urban america they'll
cast people who are black yeah but
they're it has yet or if there's a show
about women no cast females black people
but if there's a show about autism
and it is yeah
go are you gonna say something i i this
actually brings up a good topic and we
touched on it a little bit when sarah
silverman was here do you because we
were talking about
she says that if there's a jewish
character they should be played by
jewish people yeah i watched that do you
hear that spraying sound
yes that was lou putting in breath
freshener hey you know what are you
gonna kiss him i do i've done the same
thing over and over and over again and
got different results take that einstein
okay all right but my question is and
then there's a lot of arguments on the
other side
seems like the same result to me but not
bad
there's an argument on the other side
from actors that if you're an actor then
i know it's disgusting right his
coughing well the same result every time
he sprays that stuff it makes him god
you cough from the stomach and that one
that's deep
oh that's his ass that was below the
stomach
i could hear it there is a little phlegm
in there there is something going on yes
it's not his i mean
who's is it he
whoever uh decides to donate a look
he's working on something so this show
go ahead what you were saying you were
saying something no i want to know your
belief like you were saying that
these characters are people that are
played by actual people that are on the
spectrum right do you believe that
whatever it may be whether it's autism
or jewish or is it the big two
gay
right that's up there yeah well do you
think it should be played by someone who
is authentically i have a very strong
category i have a very strong take on
this okay brilliant question
i do not believe
that
any of these things need to be
played by
somebody who has the most authentic
truth in their real life to it i don't
think that only people with autism
should be playing autistic characters
you could argue it's not for me to say
but i don't feel that way about
homosexual i don't feel that way about
jewish
i do think outside of
outside of giving
people opportunity which is a variable
and should be considered and exists
from a selfish point of view when you're
telling a story you want somebody who
could bring the most authentic thing to
it so when you have
somebody who's lived a certain life and
knows a certain thing they could just
tell this story a little bit better but
it's a it's a
it's a fine line to then only say only
these people could do it because then
you're not acting anymore and everyone
is only playing themself
i think it's great
that
our show isn't just casting
neuro-diverse people to play
neurodiverse characters there are um the
guy who plays my boss uh and i'm i'm not
embarrassed but i just don't remember
his name and maybe i could tell it to
you and we could put it up on the screen
yeah
jeremy put the name of the key i'll send
it to you yeah right but look up the
cast of that and then we'll say
he's great your father we know is um
he's not he's not one of the uh the
principal he's done a few episodes but
he has autism and he plays a
neurotypical character
and the writing staff and the pas and a
lot of people on the production have
autism so or are directly connected to
it
it just fosters an environment of just
people that what's that nurturing acts
yeah
which i just feel is ironic that like
when people have this idea of the way
we're supposed to be around a certain
type of person which they are making
this thing up they're just nicer
and more accepting and this thing is
just like everyone was just calm and i
don't know why that has to be on an
autistic set but
but you didn't know about your own
autism until that's why i was a little
nervous about this show not to play the
character which i felt i could do well
but
if the show works and i have to do this
stuff
i just felt like who am i to talk about
this stuff and oh you you quoted
somebody which i thought was a brilliant
quote you met one person with autism it
means you had one person with autism um
and that was very true on set when i met
uh suan and albert of which i just did a
podcast with them i don't know when this
comes out but it probably just came out
but we talked about this podcast has not
been out yet oh you don't do live
this is not live oh well then you could
go and check it out um
everyone is so d everyone is so
different and the characters they're
playing are so different and it made it
easier for me to accept that like i
don't have to be an advocate for autism
as much as just speak my truth from
my
experiences learning about what i know
about autism and
maybe that is what an advocate is well
an advocate listen i'm not cutting you
off am i covering your mouth that's what
you do i know anyway
the thing is when i watch the show
my wife and i we go
oh my god this reminds me of so-and-so
or this is what it's like so what it
teaches us not only is it entertaining
and uh thought-provoking but it teaches
us
and i don't know if that was the point
of the show rather than just this is an
interesting slice of life to kind of
depict for entertainment purposes but it
teaches us to have uh patience and to be
more cognizant you know i think if
there's one problem in the world it's
like if somebody's different looks
different acts different is different
than me
we don't like them we have no patience
with them we don't understand them and
this kind of shows us
you know another side that
hasn't really been
you know shown
[Music]
you